the Joe Rogan experience it's almost
like new should be nonprofit I got a
[ __ ] breaking story for you I forgot
well I I cannot believe I almost forgot
this ooh
so you know the guy in those texts that
the big black guy yes
yeah let's explain that is a trick
people always say the link oh my god
it's it's now killing more 20-year olds
than any disease every like what what he
clicked the link and this is Jack black
dude with a dick that looks like my leg
sitting on the edge of the bed looking
like he's like have you seen a bigger
dick right that's what his expression is
when it's limp its limp yeah there is
area yeah so news yeah this is Bram
knows he's dead right he's dead he died
a few years ago so and by the way that
the the that meme of like kind of has
gone viral I mean right every I mean you
know I get 25 a day from different
people I have a doctor friend who sends
me I'm like Jesus Christ so it's like
it's not just in like a dramedy sort and
I'm sure people listening or watching
have have have seen it as well so I was
like meh who is this [ __ ] guy right
like I you kind of just get curious you
keep seeing this and it's like sort of
like this sense of relief of from the
seriousness of the day right yeah you'll
you'll be having you just seen like
these people to hide and you know
quarantined and then you get this
ridiculous text and it's this guy so I
saw an article where the photographer
who took that photo was like ah he was
like oh it's so sad that people are
using his image that way because you
know he passed away and and I'd you know
he thought it was kind of offensive that
he was being used to prank or whatever
and he said you know I I saw that people
started selling merch with this guy's
face on it and he goes I just wish he
goes I own the photograph and I'm not
trying to come after him when I just
wish they would share proceeds of that
merge with the family so I saw that and
I was like oh I want to do that
so I launched a shirt with that guy's
face on it that says wash your hands and
then and then I go I go I want to give
the proceeds to this man's family so
because of that article I reached out to
people I was able to get in touch with
the photographer the guy who took that
picture and then I found I got in touch
with his the the models fiance who you
know his ex P I mean whatever he passed
away so anyways I contacted her I found
her I've learned a little bit about this
guy in that photo and I'm giving them
the proceeds from the shirt sales all of
them all the profits will go to them and
I also found that when he when he died
like the family wasn't prepared like
financially for anything so they had set
up a GoFundMe for his funeral and
tombstone and all that so I'm I'm gonna
blast it out and I talked beautiful
they're happy with it so that's not
breaking news that's the break that's
the break that's important news Jamie
told me his dicks not really as big I
didn't get into that with her I Jamie
said that it's photoshopped I've heard
that as well seen I saw the original
blog post that came from you did let's
see what the original how I have to find
it now oh please don't tell me that's
gonna take a while let's see the
original hogg please he's google it so
like I have to find the link just Google
original big penis guys I'm sure show me
the original black dick yeah but she was
funny she was like you know there's
crazy when I reached it I found it took
me like I was doing like detective work
right now enough to find her and she was
like I found out about this meme today
oh she was like I didn't even know this
was a thing how did she find out people
are not sending it to her I think so
yeah and then someone was like husband
hello well yeah so yeah yeah uh anyways
yeah oh well first of all she's engaged
to a porn star that's good no but she
wasn't she wasn't no she's lying to me
she goes you know he was she goes he did
those photos when it was a really bad
time in his life he needed money to save
the house that he grew up in that was
his now oh so he just starts slinging
that big deck yeah started feeling that
dig around and how much money can make
slinging dick as a dude I think if he
some 50 bucks know how it was harvest
tops when he died what are you doing I
finally just found that link and other
guys original dick they took me to a
[ __ ] I'm deep on the internet right
now oh do you want to see where I'm at
or let's just show the dick let's see
the original dick neck he's like a
deeper it's huge it's a different
picture but that's a different picture
but it's the same photo shoot right but
where's the the actual photo where you
see whoa see that's someone's ass scroll
down keep scrolling
oh this is a know your meme thing guys a
giant dick there dude I don't know what
you're talking about with the same one
it's a different well that's a weird
angle right there any way you could make
that bigger so we can let's do a giant
[ __ ] looks like it's not a small dick I
think you're wrong Jamie I think it's
the same hog that muscle bear Oh muscle
bear so he was doing that kind of porn
yeah oh okay I think he's doing looks
like he's doing solo shots you know okay
pictures of me I need somebody beat you
off yeah there's a lot of money in that
maybe I don't know starting only fans
Jamie um well what were we just talking
about before that
[Applause]